[Music]
hello there the final update of season
seven is here the end of season event is
fast approaching and things are about to
take a turn for the worst on br island
this may be the last time we see the
current island there's a metric ton of
law to go through today and of course
the usual map changes that make no sense
but make us all happy all the same be
sure to slap in a creator code if you
buy cosmetics on fortnite is mine if
you'd be so kind but a simple like is
just as helpful let's see what week 13
has in store for us all
[Music]
with every update this season i run
straight to the hashtag tiny chair hill
from the days it sat proud on this hill
all alone to the day it shrank so small
we could barely see it last update the
chair was added to with a bear and a
telescope and now take a look this week
i'll give you a second to see if you can
spot the very important change here you
got it it's slightly bigger this week
yep that's the hard hitting content you
come here for right the chair is less
tiny right now if i had to guess what
happens next i believe the chair will
regrow to its original size along with
the bear and telescope it's an
absolutely pointless update but i like
it let's crack on this week we saw the
change in name to the former slurpee
swamps it's now sludgy swamps this is
actually a pretty big deal around these
parts we are now unable to claim shields
by walking through the swamplands after
the aliens took away slurpee it no
longer produced slope juice which could
mean this is officially the worst spot
to land in fortnite right now but hey
every cloud has a silver lining because
when epic takes something away they give
us something in return get your butt
over to the farmland east of corny
complex steel farm has evolved do you
recognize the object that is added this
week hell yeah baby og hut watch is
right there i'm having flashbacks to the
original building all those years ago i
guess we've got to do this thing
this place has been upgraded extremely
slowly first the addition of a barricade
which was added to a month later when it
was fortified and right now the
overlooking tower is here i can't decide
if this is story related or just a
fortnight dev having a bit of fun if
it's the latter brofist coming your way
fortnite dev
okay there's a couple of little things
you may not have noticed in the past few
updates over at ferris bueller's house
the season three rocket league posters
are now updated to season four hate
isn't a big deal we're just here for map
changes i need your help with this next
one i cannot find the bromance anywhere
they are missing in action i may have
missed them on my search so please
please if you find them please hit me up
on twitter we need them in our life and
they also know how to bring down the
alien ship so they must be here
somewhere if you're wondering i've also
checked back on the burial site of
bushranger and i can confirm no update
here at all the weird music still plays
as the tree sits waiting to grow maybe
he'll be back just before the season
ends he's very close to the alien biome
bushranger may bloom into something new
from both those world's realities or
most likely this story will pick up in
season
so when you first clicked on fortnite
today did you notice the ui has changed
and it's going to revolutionize how we
interact with fortnite it's clear that
with the updates coming to creative user
generated content is the way forward so
quick tip
build something and release it when you
can be part of this movement and you
never know this could be your career in
years to come
i'm putting together a team of creative
builders if you're looking for one
yourself i'll link my discord below if
you'd like to join us
so on to law and the direction of the
season this update saw io leave their
secret base and if you've been keeping
an eye on challenges this season you'll
know why we now know 100
an event is coming next week to
fortnight the event countdown is in the
files and should be with us this week
sometime by the way i'll have my usual
full recap of the season up next week
ready for the event the last seven days
have actually given us a good idea of
the future there are two unfinished
quest lines right now the io mold giving
information to the aliens and io's
counter-attack against those pesky
aliens sloan has had us running errands
for weeks now which all built up to the
arrival of the bomb deep in the i o
facility in game right now sloane and
her crew are outside the bunker and the
reason is they intend to get this place
sucked into the mother ship so they can
arm that bomb and destroy the aliens
most likely during the live event and
guess what it's all your fault you armed
that bomb unless you didn't bother doing
those challenges i've got yeah that
don't work the second part of the riddle
was the i o mole gifting information to
the aliens we all thought this was joey
but after he was outed she was outed
they were outed as a double agent the
leaks continued and look away now if you
don't want anything spoiling the
imposter among us is none other than
maven the pleasant mannered bureaucrat
who was there all along is the one we
shouldn't have trusted unless you're pro
alien you do you don't let io control
you in next week's update the i o
facility will be gone and maven will be
forced to pick a side all before we
experience the end of season event it's
gonna be awesome and leakers have told
us we should expect a game ending event
like the black hole remember that one
watching and waiting for a new season to
begin there are many unanswered
questions about the whereabouts of both
jones and the foundation and the kevin
the cube theory we all hope to be true
season 8 is so close all the answers are
coming very soon will we get the rolling
brick of death once again a halloween
season like no other
i'm adam you're awesome i'll see you
next time sorry for no code adamara
legends today i actually took a break
and went outside and touched grass in
real life it was good i recommend it
i'll be back in my dms tonight thanks
for supporting me see you soon
[Music]
you